we have george gaiman here with this
george can you hear me i can i can
thanks for having me on absolutely how
are you i'm extremely well it's my
little wild ride yesterday
we got a ton to talk about my friend
let's first start off with uh just your
background i think that you've got this
incredible story in terms of running a
couple of businesses then semi-retiring
and kind of moving into becoming a real
estate investor so maybe walk us just
through how you describe your background
yeah i retired in 2012. ripe old age of
38 and uh i knew that i wanted to invest
my own money i've always liked to
kind of be in control
i never wanted to delegate that to a
financial planner and i was in singapore
during the summer
and i had about 10 minutes before a
dinner date i was at the marina bay
sands
and ironically i was on youtube and i
stumbled across some videos from a guy
named milton friedman
and it was his series free to choose i'm
sure you've seen and that took me right
down the rabbit hole it resonated with
me and it i just really felt the
connection he was articulating
everything that had been in the back of
my mind for so long and that took me
to study people like thomas sowell
and then investors like jim rogers
jim grant jim rickards i actually just
did a panel discussion with jim grant in
new orleans last week so that was a
definitely a highlight something i'll
remember for a long long time but that
kind of got me into that mindset of
value investing and then i kind of
studied macro through that lens and then
i just became obsessed with it and i was
just you know like all of us right
whenever we're in the shower whenever
we're taking a jog or at the gym
uh we're always just listening to the
most recent podcast or audio book or
something like that to try to better
understand the world around us
in 2012 uh just fast forward a couple
months i knew that i wanted to buy
things when they were cheap and sell
them when they're expensive
so
that at the time real estate was cheap
so i got involved with real estate in
the midwest
and then i made actually quite a bit of
money overseas as an entrepreneur prior
to retiring
so once i understood the real estate
game here in the u.s i thought i could
get a little bit better returns overseas
so i went down to south america and
bought some property there then in 2015
i wanted to actually go long oil believe
it or not because it was under 30 a
barrel
and uh i did but i didn't know you know
the one thing that i learned very
quickly as an entrepreneur that has
served me well
is you got to know what you don't know
and i knew back then that okay i kind of
understand this this economic stuff but
i don't understand oil but i do know
that it's cheap just looking at a
historic chart adjusted for inflation so
then at the time i was in ecuador i said
you know what the colombian peso
is kind of loosely tied to oil because
it's such a large percentage of their
exports
so maybe if i buy something denominated
in pesos that's kind of uh an artificial
way of going long
oil itself
and i said okay well i do know real
estate so if i buy real estate
denominated in pesos then i've got the
benefit of knowing what i'm doing and
then also that benefit of kind of my
long idea
uh with oil and so that took me to
medellin colombia and i've been
investing in real estate there ever
since 2015. in 2019 we were doing so
many projects and i had a team i thought
well might as well turn this into a tv
show
something like hgtv so i'd never done
that in my life but and i don't even
know how the hell i did it but i went
down to the local tv station it's called
telemedine
and i pitched them on me producing this
tv show that included myself and my i
kind of the team that that works with me
it's really headed by uh husband and
wife team angie's my uh designer and
joaquin is my architect so we were on
the show bottom line they greenlit the
project i had to hire all the camera
people and editors so we got done with
season one everything went well we were
kind of in a a delay between we when we
start season two
so i wanted to keep them busy so i
started a youtube channel
initially it was about real estate
because i didn't think anyone would want
to watch a video on macro but that was
my real passion but what ended up
happening is when i did whiteboard
videos on macro those are the ones that
really took off and that was kind of
summer 2019 and
the rest is history i guess
so i want to talk about the
macroeconomic picture first right we
live in a time that uh seems pretty
historic uh last year we had this public
health crisis that whipped around the
world we saw governments mandate
lockdowns it ground the global economy
basically to a halt
and we had the liquidity crisis of may
2020 they stepped in specifically in the
united states but elsewhere as well they
manipulated interest rates down they
printed a bunch of money stuffed in
every corner of the financial market
and if we zoom out now and look about 18
months later asset prices exploded cpi's
at over 5 for multiple months there's 11
million open jobs in the u.s economy in
uh unemployment it's over four and a
half percent uh and it feels like uh
there's chaos there's uncertainty and
nobody knows what's going on right it
feels like the house is on fire and
nobody's in charge of putting it out
how do you view where we are today and
like how did we get here is that a fair
assumption that a lot of what we're
seeing now is because of the monetary
and fiscal decisions last year or is
there some more larger trend that gets
us here
i i think both because when you go back
to quantitative easing in 2008 you see
that it's just uh monetary heroin as our
good friend peter schiff would say
and uh and in order to keep that heroin
addict uh really high on the drug or
functional you have to give them more
and more heroin and this is why the
fed's balance sheet went from 800
billion in 2008 to 4 trillion and they
tried to back pedal a little bit that
didn't work and now all of a sudden
we're up to eight trillion and it'll
have to go to 10 trillion it'll have to
go to 15 trillion if there's just no way
to to stop it without that
heroin addict going through the
withdrawals
and
the politicians and the central planners
that are in charge right now they don't
have the stomach to do what is necessary
to get us back to
an economic foundation that is sound
we don't have a paul volcker and even if
we did i don't know that they could do
what they did back in let's say 1980 or
81 where they jack rates up to 18
percent and basically cause a recession
to
get out all the male investment and
misallocation of resources
but i think what what people need to do
if they're trying to figure out the
probability of what's going to happen in
the future especially with prices
because i think that's what most people
are interested in and what's going to
happen with inflation is this transitory
is it something more permanent like the
1970s
uh could this turn into excuse me
a deflationary bust like the 1930s if if
the government stops this deficit
spending
because i believe we've gone from a fed
put to a government put so in order to
figure those things out to the best of
our ability i think we have to
understand how dollars are created in
the first place
so if we go back prior to 2020
97 of the dollars that circulate in the
real economy i like to say on the
the asset side of the balance sheet of
the non-bank entities in the real
economy those are created by the
commercial banks
those were lent
into existence
so if you have commercial bank lending
go down you should have a decrease in
the amount of dollars that are
circulating in the real economy now that
doesn't have anything to do
with the amount of reserves that are on
the balance sheet of the fed uh people
get confused there they think that
there's some sort of causal effect when
the fed's balance sheet increases that
also must mean that there are more
dollars circulating in the real economy
that's that isn't necessarily true
so but then we've got to fast forward
to 2020 and now all of a sudden that the
system changes from the standpoint of
the government comes in and deficit
spins to the tune of let's call it five
trillion dollars
and the majority of those treasuries end
up on the balance sheet of the fed so
they're directly monetizing the debt why
is that important and why is it
different
because now when janet yellen spends
those stemi checks as an example that is
creating additional dollar money supply
that didn't exist before because if the
government were to deficit spend
prior to 2020 usually what would happen
is they'd sell the bonds and those
dollars to buy the bonds would come off
the balance sheets of the non-bank
entities in the real economy so when the
treasury spent those dollars back into
existence
on net balance it was a wash
you see but what's happening when the
fed buys the debt it's different because
they're printing bank reserves
denominated in dollars liabilities of
the fed to buy those bonds so the
dollars aren't being pulled out of the
real economy to begin with that's why
you saw m2 money supply although i don't
really like that measurement but that's
why you saw it just really skyrocket
along with the fed's balance sheet in
2020 and we're seeing the same thing in
2021 i think that's one of the main
reasons we've had this huge spike of
inflation so then to figure out the
probabilities of this continuing if you
if we're just looking at the demand side
of the equation because i think the
supply side of the equation is a
completely different set of
probabilities and we'll address that in
a moment if you want to
but just the demand side
okay well if the government is in a
stalemate and they can't pass these four
five eight trillion dollar spending
bills that they need to can to continue
this
wave of inflation well then we could go
into an environment where we see
disinflation depending on how much
spending they're actually doing but if
that if we get into that mode especially
if it affects the stock market because i
believe the real economy is completely
tied to the level of the stock market
and housing prices then i think the fed
or the central planners step in and do
everything they can
that's when the fed i think realizes
that they're not in control the dollar
and then they need to take action and
the only way the fed or any central bank
for that matter can actually be in
charge of the currency or control the
currency the amount of currency units
that are circulating is to have a
central bank digital currency
and so i think that's
the kind of the the third uh system that
we move into in the future we start with
the commercial banks creating the
dollars now we're in a system kind of
hybrid of the commercial banks the fed
monetizing the debt in the future i
think we go into a central bank digital
currency and in that environment i think
the probability is extremely high that
inflation remains permanent
okay so i want to talk about where we
are right now in this hybrid model with
inflation the official numbers 5.4 cpi 4
core inflation uh we have spent too much
time on this show talking about crazy
crazy parts of the methodology the data
collection one of our favorite examples
is that the cpi rent index still shows
about two percent rent growth year over
year but when you look at how they
calculate it they like use 1990 census
data and they basically call people up
and they're like hey what's going on at
your uh at your place oh real
realtor.com pegged it at 12 so 12
apartment.com is at 14 and zillow's at
like eight or nine percent so regardless
of whether those guys are right or not
directionally every single uh platform
that has real-time data and more robust
data sets is showing something
materially higher 300 400 percent or
higher than what the cpi rent index
shows and so you can go across the
basket of goods across many of these cpi
metrics and say hey
there's all kinds of issues not
including uh also going back to the cost
of goods index versus the cost of living
index and kind of the manipulation of
the data
so what do you think inflation actually
is right now we know what the official
numbers are where do you kind of peg it
and then how long do you think that this
is going to persist and it sounds like
maybe you actually think it's here
forever moving forward
okay so to start i think probably 10 12
i think it's very similar to what we saw
in the
1970s as far as the the real rate of
inflation and i know kathy wood just
came out and kind of had a rebuttal for
for jack dorsey uh where she was saying
that she sees deflation after christmas
but
again i don't think she really
understands how inflation is measured in
such a large portion of the cpi is
housing
and i i i realize that we're probably in
a tech uh innovative world but i don't
know how tech brings down the price of a
roof over your head
especially if we have government
restricting the supply
so i think the the probability of us
staying in an inflationary environment
is extremely high i think the
probability of deflation meaning price
is actually going down as low but we
could go into an environment of dis
inflation so let's just say that over
2020 2021 so far we've seen the real
rate of inflation at 10 12 percent we
could go back down to eight percent and
that would be disinflation but prices
are still compounding
on that high water mark that was set in
let's say 2021
so that's a big problem so i think what
is most likely to happen is we see this
1940s type scenario and this is
something i've discussed with my good
friend lynn alden
at great lengths where when the
government comes in and actually agrees
on a huge spending program and then the
fed is most likely pegging the yield
curve to get uh negative real rates
then you see this big spike in inflation
but then what happens is when you have
this stalemate and they're arguing back
and forth they can't decide whether to
spend 3 trillion or 4 trillion or 2
trillion or whatever
then you see this kind of disinflation
mode or maybe six months or a year and
then they kind of wake up and they're
like oh my gosh we're gonna if we don't
spend more money we're gonna have a
catastrophe they come back out spend
more money you see a big spike
and i think that continues until we have
a massive crash in the stock market or
in housing prices now keep in mind
housing prices take a long time to go
down uh even back during the gfc they
peaked out at 2006 and we didn't hit our
bottom until about 2012.
so it doesn't happen overnight but i
think the stock market
or the real economy i should say is so
dependent
upon the stock market because the
majority of people's purchasing power is
in their 401k in aggregate total
uh that if you have a 20 30 40 down move
in the stock market and i'd like to
remind people they say oh george that's
impossible in an inflationary
environment that's not true if you look
at the 1970s from 72 to 74 the stock
market went down by 50 in nominal terms
so if that happens again
there's no way the fed or the government
the central planners can just sit back
and say okay well we'll just let all the
the malinvestment and the misallocation
of resources kind of wash itself out of
the system they're gonna have to come in
and uh and and quote-unquote do
something and i don't think the fed
uh their their fed put if you will just
expanding the size of their balance
sheet i don't think that will work i
think it expired back in march of 2020
because if you remember the fed was
supposed to have that meeting on a
wednesday and they had the emergency
meeting the sunday prior
that's when they came out and announced
qe infinity and that they'd commit to up
to a trillion a day in repo and they
dropped rates down to zero percent what
did the market do the next day it tanked
it was down by my memory serves me at
over a thousand points
and
but what happened is when the market
started to rebound is when they came out
with the cares act so that's why i say i
think we've gone from this fed put to a
government put
but what happens if the market shrugs
that off like they did with the fed put
back in march of 2020 that's when i
think they're going to be forced to go
to a central bank digital currency and
once they go to a central bank digital
currency like i said earlier then the
fed controls
to a large degree the number of dollars
that are circulating and the velocity
for that matter
and that's when i think you see that
persistent inflation
because that's what they need to bail
out the government that's that's the
only way they can get out of their 130
percent debt to gdp
is by a real default where they say
we're not going to pay you or
a covert
default which is the same thing where
they say we're going to pay you but
we're just going to pay you back with
devalued dollars so where does bitcoin
fit into all of this
how do you think about bitcoin as an
asset uh how do you think about
inflation's relationship to the bitcoin
price does inflation push bitcoin's
price up just talk to me a little bit
about the kind of decentralized digital
currency and where that fits into this
uh view of the world
yeah
i don't know that it's an inflation
hedge but it inflation would definitely
be a tailwind
that's for sure
i think that the best argument for
having bitcoin right now
has nothing to do with the price
direction
i think that the best argument for
having bitcoin now i'm bullish on the
price long term i've owned bitcoin for a
long time a lot of people on finn twit
for some reason they think i'm a a
bitcoin bearer that's not really true
it's just that i've compartmentalized
the probabilities of the price of
bitcoin going up and then the
probability of bitcoin becoming global
money and replacing all fiat currency
those are two different sets of
probabilities and people conflate the
two
but i think the best reason for having
bitcoin right now is because there is a
very real chance that if you
value freedom
more than you value safety
that you are going to be kicked out of
the banking system you may be kicked out
of society i mean we see this happening
right now and i won't go into great
detail to keep it uh
youtube friendly
but uh we see a specific group in our
population that are now not allowed into
restaurants
or they're not allowed into gyms
and maybe they won't be allowed in
grocery stores or on airplanes in the
future
so we're getting this segregation of the
population and i think that especially
when you start layering on kind of a
dehumanizing effect of that group
then
i i think there's a higher probability
than zero that that group
gets kind of excommunicated if you will
from the banking system and you know i
was talking to caitlyn long the other
day on my show and we were talking about
you know how to buy bitcoin if you were
kicked out of the banking system she
says it would be very difficult if not
impossible to do legally so that's why
i've been telling people hey
even if you think the price of bitcoins
going to go in half
who cares you got to have some just in
case you
you know get get uh kicked out of the
banking system because you're someone
who has
a dissenting view or a view that's
contrary to the mainstream narrative and
you need to keep some sort of purchasing
power with you as a plan b
i think that's the best argument for
having it right now but then i also
think there's a fantastic argument for
turning people on to bitcoin as a way to
open people's eyes to
the risk of tyranny
in our society
we see what's happening in australia
and i think as americans that should be
a wake-up call
because if that can happen in australia
it can definitely happen here as well
and so so many people on my channel uh
you know the one that got taken down yes
and reinstated they always say because i
always say at the end of the videos you
know we got to stand up and fight for
freedom fight for liberty and free
market capitalism
and they always say george well how do
we do that how do we do that we don't
have a a channel with hundreds of
thousands subscribers we don't have a
big reach like you did i remind them
that i had zero reach back in 2019 but
also i say what you can do is just
simple things is first you've got to
isolate your friends and family members
into three different groups it's just
like sales where you're going to have a
third of the group that's going to be
receptive to your message you're gonna
have a third of the group that will just
completely ignore you no matter what you
say you could have a cure for cancer and
they won't listen to you
and then you have that third in the
middle that may be your average cnn
viewer but may at least have an open
mind and that's the group that you want
to focus on now i think the wrong way to
do that is just beat them over the head
with memes on facebook as to how they're
stupid or why they shouldn't be watching
cnn or how biden sucks or something i
think a better way to do that a more
tactical approach is to maybe just start
sharing some videos like yours or maybe
ron paul i always like to use ron paul
because he's such a nice guy and you can
tell by
just listening to one of his youtube
videos for five minutes that he is
someone who is principled
and trustworthy
even if you don't agree with what he is
saying so i said start sharing some of
those but then the next thing i tell
them is hey just introduce them to
bitcoin
or introduce them to gold right now i
actually like bitcoin better because
unfortunately the way we're hardwired as
human beings
is we just want to get rich fast
and i'm sure you know so many people to
average joe and jane that really don't
understand why bitcoin is special they
don't understand the philosophy behind
it but they're attracted to it just
because they hear it on cnbc every 30
seconds or they see the price go from
let's say 40 000 up to 60 000 and like
holy cow how how do i how do i you know
they kind of get fomo but see that's a
great opportunity because even if that
fomo which i think is kind of negative
but regardless if it sinks the hook
and it gets them to understand why
bitcoin is interesting from a
philosophical standpoint then they get
introduced to austrian economics then
they get introduced to the freedom
and liberty movement
and see then what you've done by
enticing them by the price of bitcoin
going up is three months later you talk
to them and now the sudden they are also
standing up for freedom and liberty and
fighting this uh aggressive movement
towards tyranny that we have in the
united states
and so talk to me a little bit more
about this idea of bitcoin uh being able
to fight back or expose tyranny the the
idea of bitcoin being uh for freedom
right i think that there are some core
ethos that are baked into the technology
itself obviously the ideas of
self-sovereignty the ideas of uh
censorship resistance and sound money
sound money decentralization right i
mean there's a bunch of these uh
there is this weird element where those
in the developing world almost
understand the need and importance of
this more so than those in the developed
world there's definitely this like
american ignorance to some degree that
it can't happen here right uh america is
a capitalistic society it's a free
democracy
and i think your point about australia
is a great point but also as i've talked
to people there's many people who watch
this show actually people don't know
this but more than 50 percent of the
people who watch this show are not in
the united states and what they
say over and over again is i live in a
place like venezuela or i live in an
african country or i live in somewhere
in southeast asia et cetera like i've
seen this happen right i understand what
the impact is of undisciplined monetary
decisions i understand what happens when
a government starts to overreach and it
becomes a slippery slope and so is there
a situation where people in the
developed world actually begin to learn
about this without having to experience
it firsthand or is it kind of the old
adage that like the best way to learn is
the first hand experience and that's
just going to be the unfortunate reality
like how do you balance the developed
and developing world in the different
knowledge bases or experiences
well i think in the developed world they
the average john jane is going to be
pushed to considering something uh more
and more by the central banks and the
central planners and the reason i say
that is because let's just say inflation
is going up at 10 or 12 percent
well you could say okay well i've got a
401k i've got a you know or maybe a
portfolio it's a mix of 60 stocks maybe
40 bonds and although your stock
portfolio may be going up
i think
we get to a point in time very quickly
where the prices of what you're buying
on a daily basis are going up a lot
faster than your stock portfolio
and people just see usually tend to see
things just in nominal terms so they
think that if their stock portfolio goes
up by 10 percent or their house goes up
by 10 percent then they're getting
richer
but i think soon they will they will
realize like they did in the 1970s
that even if their stock portfolio goes
up by 10 if the prices of goods and
services
goes up by 20 percent you are losing
purchasing power
so what does that do
that pushes people further out the risk
curve or there or it incentivizes them
to explore other options and something
that could uh actually increase its
purchasing power relative to the rate of
inflation and right now that's that
that's cryptocurrency so i i'm not
saying that
that environment is a good thing because
i wish we had a deflationary environment
like we did in the 19 or the 1800s
so people just parked their dollars in a
bank and get a seven percent real rate
of return i think the world would be a
much much better place
but i think uh whether it's good or bad
uh i think people will be forced into
uh cryptocurrency because it's the only
thing that's out there that will be able
to keep up or exceed uh the rate of
inflation to maintain your purchasing
power they'll be pushed into it through
necessity i think that's what i'm trying
to say which creates a very interesting
dynamic if the fed and the government
right now are in the position where they
have to prop up the stock market because
that's where everyone's purchasing power
is or the housing market how does it
work when everyone's purchasing power is
in cryptocurrency
and now the sudden
you know we go from
the real economy revolving around what's
happening in the stock market in the
housing market to the real economy
revolving around what's happening with
cryptocurrency and i'm not saying that's
good or bad i'm saying it's an
observation that i think we should all
be cognizant of because it is a
probability that's higher than zero and
then ask yourself the question what does
the fed do then what is the central
planner the uh the federal government do
they come in and and bail out uh
cryptocurrency if it crashes by 50
because that would impact the real
economy so dramatically
i don't know
when you think about uh the life cycle
you've had from an investing and
entrepreneurship standpoint you owned
businesses there was cash flow you have
had equity exposure to the businesses
you owned you then uh had a bunch of
real estate both from just kind of
buying and holding as a passive capital
appreciation but also
from passive uh income and now you've
started to uh also own bitcoin you i
assume own gold as well how do you think
about the portfolio construction today
in this environment can you kind of
break us down on a percentage basis how
you're allocated
absolutely i always call it a 1080 10
portfolio
so for me and and that's why i really
don't understand the people that get in
arguments about bitcoin and gold because
philosophically we're all coming from
the same place
and to me they are not competing assets
at all they serve completely different
purposes in my portfolio so that first
ten percent for me i just consider
insurance so that would just be physical
gold for me and then the eighty percent
of the portfolio i would consider
investments now i define that as things
that pay you to own them so dividend
paying stocks positive cash flowing real
estate whether it's in the united states
or maybe it's outside the united states
that would be an example of things that
pay you to own them and i like that for
80 because i'm not that smart
so it's that kiss strategy you know keep
it simple stupid
and i think that if i can
if i can have the majority of my
portfolio that makes sense or that works
from day one that really limits my
downside you see because if i buy a a
house let's say in columbia in medellin
columbia and i'm getting a 10 return on
that based on the rents from the past uh
three years nothing needs to happen in
order for that to work out it just has
to keep doing what it's doing
but if i go out there and buy
a cryptocurrency or a gold miner which i
think would be great speculations
something actually has to happen in
order for that investment to work out
so that's how i kind of limit my
downside now that said
i'm in a a different position than
probably a lot of your viewers and
they're in different everyone's
different right and we all have
different objectives
and my objective with my own portfolio
is really my number one priority is to
maintain my purchasing power
if i was 20 years old or if i was 25
years old and
it was prior to retiring
i may have different priorities and
therefore i'd set up my portfolio
differently
and then the last 10 percent
i kind of mentioned it earlier that
would be the speculative side of my
portfolio and for me that's not a
derogatory term it just means that i see
good asymmetry there but it might not
pay me to own it so an example this
would be march of 2020 i bought a lot of
uranium
i bought a lot of coal and that was
because i thought they were good
speculations bitcoin would be i think
perfect uh for that side of my portfolio
so that's kind of how i set things up to
achieve my objectives but again my
objectives are probably different than
maybe a lot of people watching you
mentioned that bitcoin and gold are not
competing assets they're kind of served
two different purposes elaborate yeah
i just think that gold is insurance and
bitcoin is a good speculative play uh so
so you're not going to get rich off
bitcoin or excuse me you're not going to
get rich off gold i mean you got it
and i'm probably going to piss off a lot
of gold bugs here but
and i'm a huge fan of gold i think
everyone should own it
but let's think about this if gold goes
up to 10 000 an ounce
but only goes up with the rate of
inflation
you you haven't increased your
purchasing power and the problem is when
you go to sell the gold now you've got
to pay capital gains
so if the gold goes up just
in real terms
or if the gold just goes up with the
same rate of inflation
then you sell now the sudden you've got
a loss of purchasing power even if the
gold went up to call it ten thousand
dollars an ounce
where where bitcoin
you could see it could go from 40 000 to
60 000 in a week in a day maybe
and there you're actually increasing
your purchasing power above and beyond
the rate of inflation so even if you did
have to sell and pay that capital gain
you've got an increase in your actual
purchasing power and i i think
that's one of the main reasons they're
just two completely separate asset
classes now on on gold's side as a
benefit
i think there's less uh
risk that it's going to be here long
term and you know so a lot of people say
well why not just own bitcoin why not
own bitcoin i i talked to people that
said this at the new orleans investment
conference so i pissed off the gold bugs
now let me piss off the bitcoin guys
and i said the reason i think gold is
insurance is because ask yourself a
question
if you had to bet
100 of your net worth
as to what will exist
what will exist
in 100 years
gold or bitcoin what would you bet a
hundred percent of your net worth on
right now
you're talking you always kind of get
the
well
uh well that's not fair you know i'm
like it's gold i mean come on no matter
how bullish you are on bitcoin and i
would be one of those people you gotta
admit the problem now the probability of
bitcoin not being here may be
extraordinarily low
but i don't think it's as as as low as
gold not being here
so when you start to think about your
investing strategy one of the uh folks
that i i find absolutely fascinating in
the kind of professional investing world
is uh mark spitznagel i don't know if
you're familiar with him or not no um
but but mark uh comes from the austrian
school of economics from a philosophy or
thought process uh and he essentially
loses money all year long every year and
he bets on these tailwind kind of risk
events uh like in march 2020 and he
returned in i believe was february march
of 2020 like 4
400
right and so best performing hedge fund
for that period of time but before that
basically he's serving as insurance so
people know that they're going to lose
very small amounts of money and he's
buying out of the money options um and
he's written a book uh the dao of
capital that i've read and what is
shocking to me is that much of the
philosophy of what he is doing is he is
essentially betting over long periods of
time on highly asymmetric events
occurring that have drastically you know
kind of ridiculous payoffs when they do
happen um and he's willing to uh kind of
endure the pain year after year after
year after year between these events and
so if you think about you know in kind
of a generalized way the global
financial crisis the next one was march
of 2020. so you went almost a decade or
maybe even a little more than a decade
between these events but then you get
the best performing hedge fund and so
what ends up
taking away from for me from that story
and his strategy in that book is it
feels like when there's high levels of
inflation when asset prices are
exploding when it feels like everyone
around you is getting richer
there is a lack of long-term planning
like the art of thinking long-term is
almost lost because there's this
constant
competition who can get more who can do
more who can do whatever
one of my brothers here is uh 25 years
old and him and i laugh all the time he
actually is quite educated understands
uh a lot of this stuff and uh he has his
friends and we talk about what his
friends invest in and he once said to me
on last year he said my friends never
invest in a single asset unless they
think it's going to go up 10x
but why but you have to ask why
because of the fed yeah because i'm
serious
because when you have inflation that
that's created by the the fed or the
government and that's their their
mandate even if it's going up two three
percent compounded since 1913 that means
that the dollar loses 97 percent of its
value
so if the dollar is losing 97 of the the
value and we've gone decades where we
have negative real rates that whether
it's conscious or subconscious and i
would argue with your your brother's
buddies it's probably subconscious
but they realize that if they put their
money in a bank they're going to lose
purchasing power they have to do
something with it they have to go out
and speculate they have to they have to
buy nfts they have to buy shibu enu
because it's gone up a thousand percent
in the last 10 minutes you know they
have to do something with it and that's
why i always say the fed and the central
planners they push people further and
further out the risk curve but
unfortunately what happens is all those
people that get pushed out the risk
curve usually they don't really know
what they're doing they're not going to
have diamond hands if you will because
they're not going to understand the
philosophy behind why they're buying uh
what they're buying and what they own in
their portfolio and when we do have that
10-year event
they're the ones that get wiped out
what questions do you guys have hey
george uh nice to meet you thanks for
joining us uh so so my question would be
kind of off of that topic a little bit
which is we have a lot of younger people
that watch this show and you've built
businesses scaled businesses you
obviously understand the macro
environment environment really well uh
you understand the content space on the
internet really well obviously so my
question would be like if you were back
in your 20s right early 20s and you had
to start all over again uh is there a
specific space or industry that you
would focus on now uh that you're
excited about
let me give you an answer from from
right field here
because i thought about this a lot i
thought about you know if i had to start
over what would i do
and
i think the best thing young people can
do to to make money quickly in order to
invest in that business and i think
they should all look at doing an online
business so they can have the freedom of
mobility first and foremost because i
think in the future you know at the end
of the day it doesn't matter how much
bitcoin you have how much gold you have
onto real estate if you haven't got
freedom you got nothing
right and if someone has a business
where they can just pick up their laptop
and go to mexico or columbia or sweden
or whatever area has uh you know a
degree of freedom that's going to be
their biggest asset you can let's go
back to australia right so i think that
needs to be kind of the the end game for
for most uh young people who are are
comfortable with that lifestyle may be
comfortable with that type of business i
i know it's not for everybody but in
order to get that seed capital what i do
it's kind of like a garyvee thing you
got to learn to flip stuff you got to
learn uh to add value and when i was
2017 my younger brother
got very ill where i needed to come back
to the united states and and help him
out and care for him for about a year
and so i moved him down to tucson and
long story short i was just bored out of
my mind and so i started uh buying rvz's
airstreams as kind of uh you know just
an investment store value keeping them
in uh
storage but then i also started buying
these trucks and i i noticed that some
of the trucks i'd sell i didn't want i'd
make a really good return on them and so
i i you know buy them low miles and a
specific uh group of trucks they're
95 to
uh 2002 fords with a 7.3 power stroke
engine they're very believe it or not
they're extremely high uh value truck
they're in high demand for kind of those
truck guys that like that but what i do
is i'd buy them off craigslist from
someone who didn't really know what they
were doing or someone in california that
had to pay five bucks a gallon for gas
and then i'd fix them up and make them
look good and then i'd flip them i'd put
them on ebay at a national market and i
i mean i'd have 7 000 into a truck and
you'd sell it on ebay for
14 15 000 i mean you double your money
like almost monthly
so the reason i say that is because
although it sounds kind of
crazy i mean you could do that with very
low seed capital and if you know what
you're doing and it doesn't have to be
trucks it doesn't have to be cars it
doesn't it could be anything i mean
garyvee i think he's done it with like
sneakers and baseball cards you just
have to be an expert at something you've
got to study it non-stop obsessively for
like two or three months so you know
where there's there's value and where
there's a spread and then you go ahead
and you buy that you you know you you
sell it to someone you buy it at a local
level and you learn how to negotiate and
then you sell it at a national level
pocket the spread and then that gives
you your 20 30 40 50 grand that you need
you go ahead and start that online
business that is kind of the end game
goal that will give you maximum amount
of freedom another neat thing about that
process is you learn
the fundamentals of entrepreneurship
that apply to
running a business or uh investing in
real estate and that is you've got to
know how to manage people
first and foremost
and very few people do but if you buy a
couple trucks and you got to hire an
auto body shop you got to hire a guy for
the interior you got to hire a guy to do
the electric or the tires or you you
have to learn how to manage people and
that's a skill set that you can use in
your business or it's a skill set the
exact same skill set you'd have to use
if you're running a huge real estate
portfolio you know i was just on a
flight uh with my good buddy kenny
mcelroy we were speaking in uh dallas at
the sovereign man event we were flying
back with kiyosaki
and kenny manages over a billion dollars
in real estate uh with his funds
and uh
he uses the same things the same
techniques that a young person would use
if they were just learning how to
flip cars or tennis shoes or anything
else and that goes back to managing
people it also
involves uh
being ambitious and a self-starter
because you're not getting a paycheck
and uh no one's gonna be there to make
sure that you're clock [ __ ] in on
time you've got to do all that yourself
but then also third you've got to be a
problem solver you have to be able to
solve problems in a decisive manner so
if you've got those three things then
most likely it's just going to be a
numbers game you're going to do well and
you're going to succeed in business but
i think that's kind of a
a process that the person a young person
could go through where they'll find
themselves at 30 years old and a very
good position financially with a great
skill set that's applicable to almost
anything and then a good uh nest egg and
a good portfolio that they can invest
yeah and anyone flipping used cars over
the last year has probably done pretty
well
well i've got i i still keep a bunch of
trucks those old trucks in storage and
it would blow your mind how much they've
gone up in price i actually see those as
a good store of value a little bit like
the insurance and uh in gold as well but
again i know it sounds crazy but if you
think about the concepts behind what i'm
saying i think it'll it'll make sense
well george the average uh used car
right the index is up like 40
year-over-year so if you're buying the
right ones uh obviously they're probably
up more than 40 was pretty good
investment john what questions you have
yeah hi george nice to meet you um so
can we talk about that how you
kind of construct your portfolio you
have that 1080 10 strategy with 10
insurance 80 kind of cash flow assets
and then 10 speculative bets can you
talk about that 80 a little bit more
what businesses do you like what stocks
do you like specifically and then kind
of like what you look for in real estate
investments
okay so with real estate investments
i'm really looking for what i call a one
percent rv ratio and i get that term for
my buddy jason hartman so that's uh we
have a little bit different definition
but it's basically your monthly rent
relative to your cost basis
so if i'm a hundred thousand on a
property i only get at least a thousand
dollars a month for rent
and uh now if this if we're talking
about americans right now they're in a
very unique
situation because number one the housing
markets in a massive bubble
but number two they can actually secure
30-year fixed-rate debt
most americans don't understand that's
rare that's subsidized by the government
most countries don't have that
so
what's interesting about that is and
i'll probably go off on a tangent here
so you have to bring me back in a moment
but i think the if someone is looking at
real estate in the united states right
now they have to look at their balance
sheet the opposite
of the way they used to
when we were in a quote unquote normal
real estate market so what i mean by
that
is let's say the 1990s or the 1980s
someone would buy a house and that would
be an asset on their balance sheet well
if they had to take out a mortgage to
buy the house that would be a liability
on their balance sheet today i think
it's reversed i think the property is
actually the liability because prices
are so high but the debt the 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage is the asset
and so why were people willing to
take that bet if you will back in the
80s and 90s and going you know all the
way back to 1900 to 100 years 200 years
because they felt as though
although they were going to lose
purchasing power paying back the debt
with interest
they would gain more than that with the
purchasing power with the asset
appreciating in value
right
so
i think again it's the opposite today
where you may lose purchasing power on
the asset because you're buying prices
when they're at all-time highs
but yet you might make or you probably
will make even more purchasing power by
paying back
that debt with devalued dollars in the
future see because it's a fixed rate
loan
so i think that's if someone is
considering buying rental property in
the united states or even buying a home
that they live in i think that if they
go into it with that mindset
they're going to make much better
decisions
so
now moving back to the original question
so i start with that that metric and
although i don't really think you can
get that very often in the united states
there are other countries where that is
very realistic uh now let me warn your
viewers uh going in and buying real
estate in medellin columbia there's a 99
chance that you get your butt handed to
you
uh 99 chance you lose a lot of money
but if you are a local expert if you go
down there if you do the homework if you
do the boots on the ground research
there is a massive amount of opportunity
because the real estate market in those
other countries
is so inefficient
right they have very little debt in the
system they don't have an mls most
people sell houses in medine by just
putting up a for sale sign in their
window but literally
and so you can really
get your cost basis down relative to
your rents so so that's what i look for
first and foremost
also
especially with the united states i
would look for your political risk
so if i was buying residential
rental properties
there is no way i would do it in
california there's no way i'd do it in
illinois there's no way i'd do it in new
york i would really exclusively look at
areas like arizona maybe all this kind
of a little on the fence now but
especially texas florida if you could
get a good cash flowing rental property
there where you had positive cash flow
that that's the key yeah i don't want to
imply that you get that 30-year fair
straight mortgage and because that's
such a great asset you're being paid to
short the dollar basically that you
could have a negative carry you still
have to have good solid positive cash
flow it needs to be in the right
neighborhood all those things need to be
aligned before i would consider it for
my own portfolio
now as far as what other things pay you
to own them i think a great example of
that just to give you an actual name
would be rio tinto now it's not
something that i own it's not something
that i'm buying but it's definitely on
my watch list
uh you know we could talk about china
and evergrand fantasia what's happening
there at the residential real estate
market which is 30 of their gdp and how
they could very likely or it's very
likely that they go into a
a recession but uh the bottom line is
they
they china uh equaled about 50 of global
demand for iron ore
so you have the price of iron ore has
really collapsed now it's still up
relative to its uh 20-year average
adjusted for inflation but it's gone
down significantly over the last call it
two months so rio tinto a large
percentage of their revenue is iron ore
but they've also got a little nickel
they've got copper they've got they've
got assets that are
hard assets you know they're backed with
with real stuff that we're going to need
especially if we go into like a green
new deal
type of situation
so then you look at how safe their
dividend is and it's pretty safe based
on the cash on their on their balance
sheet but then you look at their price
it's come down so far because of what's
happened in china and iron ore that
they're paying a 10 dividend yield
so and i'm not saying that that's you
know 100 safe or anything but and i'm
not and i'm not suggesting that as an
investment but that's just an example of
something that's on my watch list uh
that i find interesting right now and an
example of that 80 of my portfolio that
i would consider an investment that's
defined by something that pays me to own
it
george before we let you go the one
thing that i want to talk about with
bitcoin is uh in one of your recent
videos you talked about bitcoin uh
potentially being purchased by the
federal reserve or the u.s government uh
we've obviously seen el salvador go
ahead and kind of plug into the network
right they've set up a bunch of atms uh
they've created a fund they're handing
bitcoin uh to people who sign up for
their bitcoin wallet that they've
created and they seem to really kind of
be pushing it forward in a way that no
other nation state has done what are
your thoughts in terms of the us
government's relationship with bitcoin
should they buy it will they buy it how
do you think about it
very difficult you know are we saying
that bitcoin is still a digital kind of
uh
asset or like a reserve asset a store of
value or is it is it money is it
competing with the dollar because then i
think the the fed or the the central
planners do different things
also is the stock market crashing and or
is uh have we gotten to a point in the
united states where the economy is so
dependent upon
cryptocurrency or maybe asset prices in
general and a good portion of that would
be crypto i'm thinking three years down
the road as an example you know would
they need to step in and actually buy
that uh buy stocks would they need to
step in i mean they're already buying
mortgages obviously to prop up that
market but would they need to buy
cryptocurrency to prop up those markets
so there there wasn't a decrease in
aggregate demand because they're all
keynesians at the end of the day so
that's their nightmares that aggregate
demand somehow goes down and if that's
the only way to maintain aggregate
demand that may incentivize them to do
that now as far as taking it onto their
balance sheet
as a reserve asset
potentially but but i don't think they
would if bitcoin is uh competing against
the dollar directly in their eyes
in their eyes
uh i think they may be incentivized and
especially other central banks may be
incentivized to do that if they continue
to see uh
bitcoin exclusively as just a digital
reserve asset
so
without opening a can of worms uh two of
the countries that i could easily see
being very interested who have publicly
stated they'd like to get off the dollar
system uh but who have ultimately failed
to do it up until now is russia and
china uh do you think that it's more
likely that maybe an uh a competitor to
america uh would do it or do you think
it's more likely that the u.s like like
i'm very fascinated by this idea of like
the global game theory and when somebody
like el salvador with six and a half
million people does it i think there's
some people who say whoa like that
that's an inflection point that that's
interesting there's a lot of other
people who just say hey they got six and
a half million people there's kind of
consolidated power you essentially have
a president and his brothers who are
younger they're forward thinking from a
technology perspective and so you know
it kind of makes sense
it's very different if uh the rumors
around brazil potentially doing
something we've seen some legislation uh
kind of presented or if the united
states was to do it or russia or china
and some of these like large large
countries with hundreds of millions of
people
so how do you just think about uh you
know i guess like the competition among
the super powers the people who actually
have very large citizen bases and
frankly have just large economies that
uh this isn't such a simple uh decision
it's just like hey we're gonna buy some
we're gonna get 30 everyone who
downloads the wallet and if we screw it
up well we're dollarized country and it
may not be as uh kind of a big of an
issue given that we wouldn't really be
risking our own currency like how do you
think about that
well if you've got a brazil and so
you're talking about the central bank
taking it onto their balance sheet
uh just simply as a reserve asset like
they would gold or something like that
is that what you're referring to yeah i
think and again some of this is just
like we don't know exactly what they're
doing but it if you look at like russia
russia has openly said hey they're going
to be a net seller
of dollars for sure they want to get rid
of their dollar assets uh in some cases
i think it was maybe a year or two ago
central banks around the world were net
sellers of gold for one quarter so not
kind of a persistent thing but but they
basically for the first time in a long
time had become a net seller and so you
start to think about okay that would
lead me to believe that they're at least
evaluating what are the assets that are
in the reserves and then what are the
assets that we could potentially move to
and there's some reallocation that goes
on
uh it feels like you know there's some
threshold i don't think it's at a
trillion dollars but is it at five
trillion dollar market cap 10 trillion
20 trillion you know where's that
threshold where eventually bitcoin
becomes so big and it does have enough
of a track record where one of the large
central banks says hey we're not going
to use this as a medium of exchange or a
threat to our kind of reserve currency
of our economy but we are going to use
it as a reserve asset in our central
bank just like we would gold or anything
else
i think it's interesting especially if
the country had a tendency to be short
dollars like in argentina right so
you i think there's a good argument why
they would buy bitcoin and keep it on
their balance sheet so the price of
bitcoin goes to let's say five hundred
thousand dollars
uh now all of a sudden they can sell
that reserve asset and get a lot of
dollars that they wouldn't otherwise
have access to and infuse that into the
commercial banking system
to kind of paper over
any
dollar shortfalls they had because of
the amount of debt that's denominated in
dollars outside of the united states so
let me give you a specific example uh i
don't know if you guys saw the news last
week but china issued four billion in
bonds denominated in dollars
right so you got to think okay why the
hell are they doing that and i actually
had this conversation with brent johnson
uh we had dinner in new orleans and we
were talking about this
and you you look at evergrand and you
look at fantasia or these other real
estate companies they have a lot of
dollar denominated debt
and so if they don't have the dollar
cash flow coming in to service that debt
which it seems like they do not then
what what is their option well they'll
most likely have to roll the debt over
well that would mean going back to the
bank and saying hey we need another loan
to pay off this loan that is that is
coming due well if the the chinese bank
doesn't have the dollars and i i don't i
want to say this carefully because i'm
not implying that they would actually
lend
the the dollars to
um evergrand because a bank loan creates
new dollars or money fiat currency that
did not exist before but they would need
some sort of dollar denominated asset to
transfer to the other bank if they had
to transfer the liability that they had
just created as a loan to ever grant in
the first place and i know that gets
really confusing but the bottom line
there is if if these banks didn't have
those dollars as reserve assets then
they wouldn't be able to issue and
extend more loans
in a fractional reserve type of way you
know lever up and therefore those
corporations wouldn't have access to the
dollar liquidity they needed
right so
the dollars you know at the end of the
day although they're slowly declining as
far as percentage of world trade they
still equal like 50 or 60 percent
of
transactions
and uh
and really how they're um
how they're settled
so i think if you're in argentina going
back to that example if you had uh
bitcoin and it went up to 100 or 200 or
500 and then you've got access to so
many more dollars that you didn't have
before that could bail out your
corporations or bail out your banks that
had uh taken on way way way too much
dollar denominated debt and they didn't
have the cash flows to service it
yeah it's fascinating to kind of think
about how uh everyone is scrambling in
some way some are doing it for longer
term purposes some are doing it for
shorter term purposes um before uh we
let you go where can we send people to
uh find you on the internet or find some
of the content you're putting out we we
know you got your youtube channel back
which uh which is great
i i feel like you and i are gonna say
for the time being you can come here
yeah i i was gonna say you and i are
walking on ed shells i feel like we need
to uh we're the bad boys of youtube or
something over here
uh where can we send people
oh they can just google my name it's
just george typical spelling last name
is g-a-m-m-o-n
uh yeah that's the george i guess that's
me on twitter right there uh but it's
the same name on youtube and uh all
social media it's my name awesome man
well listen thank you so much for uh for
taking that time to do this anyone who
uh who hasn't come across your content
previously is missing out so make sure
that you go and i think you have two
youtube channels right you have uh the
one that's under your name and then you
have the rebel capitalist uh as well
yeah the rebel capitalist was the one
that had uh
issues yesterday it was taken down by
youtube and then uh thanks to people
like you and other uh influence
influential people on finn twit uh like
joe rogan and uh and others i they
reinstated it last night at midnight so
we're gonna be keeping up the good fight
on the george gammon channel i interview
people a lot of macro topics
entrepreneurs liberty freedom i do
whiteboard videos and then on the rebel
capitalist channel we do five six seven
live streams a day just talking about
the news events from a framework of
liberty freedom and free market
capitalism awesome man well anyone who
uh who is not subscribed to those
channels please go subscribe go follow
him on twitter i appreciate taking the
time to do this and uh
you know just just behave yourself on
youtube i'll do the same and
we'll be good to go
all right buddy thanks for having me on
all right thank you thank you